[Music]
john
is with us in arrington virginia
arlington virginia i'm sorry hey john
how are you
i'm going good sir thank you and mrs
cruz for uh helping us i appreciate that
sure how can we help i'm having some
trouble
uh cutting loose of uh some money for a
new to me truck
i've uh i went you know i always made
plenty of money
and i always spent plenty of money even
better than i made it and
uh i sort of got myself together and now
i've got the
i've got the money and i i'm just having
a little bit of issue
releasing it it's uh it's kind of odd
how long ago was it that uh since you
had a spending problem
uh probably uh 2007 and then
you know about a year ago a friend of
mine got in
financial jeopardy and uh and i
revisited a bunch of your work
and i signed uh signed her up for
financial peace university and uh
and i got the every dollar budget and i
had to learn how to use it
so that i could help her use it and you
might find this hard to believe but your
system was better than mine
so
[Laughter]
much how much is the truck how much is
the truck
the truck is unfortunate six thousand
dollars
it's six thousand dollars fifty six
fifty six sir fifty six thousand dollars
okay thousand dollars nice truck
okay yeah and um you might be familiar
it's a
it's a roush f-150 so you may be
familiar with that yeah i had one
i got a roush raptor now so yeah it's a
beast man
it's a wonderful truck uh all right so
what's your household income
uh about 160. okay and
um you have the 56 000 and how much
other money do you have what's your net
worth
uh i've got about 700 and a 401k
and about uh 70
and uh other retirement okay and my my
house is paid for my house is paid for
okay yeah john i think you're what's
your house worth
uh house worth about uh 475
right now so you're a millionaire
i suppose yeah i don't know that i'm
yeah yes
it's not a feeling it's a math thing
it's a math thing it's not a feeling
yeah yeah 700 plus 400 is 1.1
you're a millionaire yes sir well done
i'm proud of you thank you
thank you yeah i mean at this point john
we it is funny though because
as much as we push people to sacrifice
their life to get out of debt and get
their money in order
the moment that they have to release it
and even i mean you're much further
along than even some people we talk to
but even people that are
you know starting baby steps four
through six to be like okay we saved up
money to go on a
trip are we okay spending a couple
thousand dollars on this trip like oh
you know it really does become this
weird emotional thing that you you can
let go of the money there that the facts
are there
and for you you're even further along
than those people i mean your
your house is paid for you're good you
have the cash in the bank your
retirement's good i mean everything is
lined up that you are
100 free to do this and uh
it it kind of takes some practice to
kind of get that spending muscle back in
if you will because it's like you
haven't been using it as much yeah and
what you've told yourself is
no one you you you like extend it out to
everybody
no one should ever spend on a truck
right
and then and now you're the guy doing it
you know and so but
uh you know but but the thing is no one
that's broke should
all right so the way i analyze it
nowadays is if i get ready to buy
something that feels
emotionally weird to me um
and i've got you know i'm you know you
got plenty of wealth i got plenty of
wealth we're okay we're doing good
all right is i ask myself if if i if the
thing
without any insurance just burned down
in the driveway
would i still be okay financially
right yeah your net worth would drop
0.05
if you lost 56 000 it would be nothing
you wouldn't even notice it out of a
million two
right that's right and so that helps me
always is like
you know in other words if i wanted to
just set fire to that much money in the
front yard just to watch it burn it
really wouldn't change my life
it'd be kind of strange but it wouldn't
change my life they'd question my
psychology but
you know we'd take him off the old man
has lost it but yeah
but the uh uh but he no longer has a
radio show
vernon cast the front yard
i look at it emotionally like that have
i hurt my family
have i been as a ratio to my situation
unwise no because if i could just burn
that much cash in the driveway and it
didn't bother me
i mean it didn't didn't affect my life
then i'm okay and you're in that case
dude i mean 56 thousand dollars go buy
your truck
okay thanks you guys do a lot of good
enough thank you
and i'll tell you one other thing i do
as an antidote is
uh i always make sure that if i'm going
to increase my spending i also increase
my generosity
yes sir and that just gives me emotional
permission
no okay well well it does
but i was also going to say it was
interesting one of the um
stories in the book i talk about is um
it's actually it was a family friends
but that he was like i mean
multi-millionaire
and he sold his company and then went
back and started working again and you
know i remember talking and being like
okay is that because you just didn't
want to be bored
or whatever and he was like no no i just
don't want to end up back where i was
i just went into back where i was and i
thought that's so interesting because
you're fine
but it's like this this this fear of
like 10 million
so he's fine yes totally totally but
that was one of the antidotes i write
about though is that giving aspect it's
true because if you're that kind of
tight and scared to do this you're
probably that tight and scared to
give and so yes i think you're exactly
right playing off of that though it's
like as you're spending more and your
lifestyle increases so should you're
giving
and it kind of just like opens up your
heart in all those ways and it's
percentages
yeah you know if you if you're if you
increase your lifestyle five percent
increase you're giving five percent
and you know and when you do five
percent of a lot of money it's a lot of
money right
so you still get to do a lot of stuff or
if it's eight percent or twelve percent
it doesn't matter
but the point is is that you're not
making fifty six thousand dollars a year
and have a hundred and ten thousand
dollars in student loan debt and call me
up wanting to lease a 56 thousand dollar
truck
which is most of america which is why we
have a career
right right that's normal america
is just plain straight up money stupid
and so i've been there too i know what
stupid looks like i've got a phd into
umb so i can readily recognize it john
you've done a great job
very proud of you sir very very proud of